on a fait exceptionnellement une
conférence de presse aujourd'hui sachez
avec l'accord bien entendu
de tous les dirigeants de C8 et du
groupe Canal+
sachez qu'aujourd'hui
si nous sommes là si nous sommes devant
vous c'est parce qu'il s'est passé un
événement absolument exceptionnel
comme tous les premiers mardi du mois
il y a le classement France de paddle
qui sort
et aujourd'hui les Chéries grâce à vous
grâce à Loïc à Sarah Agatha à Lionel
Stan à Théo Zapata et à tous mes
partenaires
qui ont fait des tournois avec moi
Adrien Maigret John bien sûr John de
Kazam
mon ami mon frère José tous ces gens qui
m'ont soutenu aujourd'hui
mon classement et
167e merci au revoir
[Applaudissements]
merci les chaises comme un fou et sachez
que c'est vraiment la direction de C8
qui m'a demandé
instamment cet après-midi d'organiser
une conférence de presse pour que bien
sûr tout le monde puisse me poser toutes
les questions concernant cette exploit
sportif voilà dont je ne suis qu'une
infime partie puisque bien sûr mes
partenaires ont été là bien sûr pour
pour me soutenir si vous avez des
questions n'hésitez pas bien sûr
Géraldine maillet oui oui
Géraldine bonjour Cyril bonjour 77 c'est
le début de quelque chose vous allez
vous arrêter où c'est le début de
quelque chose exactement il y a parfois
des gens qui m'ont dit est-ce que ce
serait pas le moment de s'arrêter non on
va aller chercher le top 100 et j'ai une
très grande annonce à vous faire dans
quelques instants ça chez nous
oui Kelly Vedovelli oui bonsoir Cyril
Hanouna j'aimerais savoir
est-ce que ça vous fait peur sincèrement
parce que vous qui n'avez pas peur de
grand chose est-ce que là toucher les
étoiles vous avez peur alors je vais
vous dire
c'est un investissement de chaque jour
de chaque instant de chaque minute de
chaque seconde et toucher les étoiles
c'est ce que j'ai voulu depuis le début
dans ce sport donc là pour l'instant on
peut pas dire qu'on les touche parce
qu'on est 177 mais on va tout faire pour
être dans le top 100 sachez que c'est
mon meilleur classement jamais atteint
167 oui oui oui
qui oui bonsoir paddle sat Hebdo est-ce
que comme Didier Deschamps vous comptez
un jour devenir entraîneur pour pousser
les Français vers l'excellence bien sûr
pour l'instant c'est vrai que je vais ma
clé à ma carrière voilà je pense que
j'ai encore des choses à prouver des
choses à donner des choses à montrer au
public et puis ensuite bien entendu j'ai
envie de transmettre c'est ce que je
veux c'est transmettre voilà pour ceux
qui vont arriver et ceux pas envie
d'être au top de son top 100 Top 50 et
pourquoi pas entraîner un jour un top 10
voilà donc c'est c'est voilà je suis je
suis là dedans oui oui Valérie benaimoun
tout pour la raquette magazine oui on a
juste Daniel Moreau la tout pour la
quéquette également si oui du top 100
est-ce que vous êtes donné un délai
est-ce que c'est dans les 6 mois dans
les dans les six ans les 6 ans non non
les dans les dans j'espère en 2024
religion pour les JO voilà merci oui
Gilles Verdez oui oui
de front plusieurs disciplines le génie
s'accommode Léonard de Vinci il est dans
quel club est-ce qu'à un moment vous
devrez choisir entre la télévision et le
paddle jamais je ne choisirais pas la
télévision c'est bien sûr c'est c'est ma
vie et le paddle c'est ma passion on ne
choisit pas entre sa vie et sa passion
ce que vous choisissez entre Fatou
et votre voix je choisis pas tout va pas
dormir
[Musique]
Cyril est-ce que vous vous êtes fait
tout seul côté paddle ou est-ce que vous
avez quelqu'un à remercier j'ai remercié
plein de gens si tu étais là au début de
la conférence de presse
apparemment t'as pas suivi ou bien tu es
un petit peu dur de la feuille voilà
donc tu remettras tu regarderas ça en
replay ce soir
merci à toi merci oui Hugo manos lui
bonsoir Hugo mano sarc-en-ciel magazine
soir j'aurais voulu savoir comment vous
faites pour avoir un corps de rêve comme
ça parce que c'est vrai que vous êtes
très musclé donc j'imagine que c'est
vous qui avez un corps de rêve je vous
retourne le contenu oui mais j'imagine
que vous avez vous avoir un entraînement
de musculation oui je vous remercie
alors justement je vous remercie
Thibault Geoffrey qui m'a fait
travailler et si j'en suis là également
je te remercie également mon kiné voilà
je vous le dis Julien qui est
extraordinaire tu viens de Sucy-en-Brie
qui est magnifique et voilà donc je
remercie bien sûr Tibo Geoffrey qui
m'ont traîné et qui m'entraîne encore et
on va aller plus haut voilà comme disait
Tina Arena merci oui Bernard Montiel oui
je le vois oui cette international oui
alors justement quand vous arrivez à des
sommets absolument incroyables vous êtes
au top du top on vous connaît très bien
en France est-ce que le succès ne vous
fera pas quitter la France nous en
serions évidemment très malheureux je
vous le dis tout de suite est-ce que
vous allez continuer à vivre en France
et à rester avec nous en France et
représenter la France dans vos
compétitions parce que vous serez le
vainqueur merci Bernard de de
sucer pendant cette
attends merci vraiment Bernard non pour
l'instant vraiment je vous avais moi je
suis français voilà et je resterai pour
l'instant aux côtés des Français pour
leur apporter ma pierre à l'édifice de
ce sport qui est en train d'exploser
voilà bravo oui bonsoir pierre de 100 %
paddle bonsoir pierre vous avez dit que
vous vous rapprochez des 100 du top 100
français est-ce que pour vous le top
mondial c'est un objectif ou pas alors
pour eux oui pour moi non parce que
voilà je vais pour l'instant je voulais
dire je veux vraiment rester en France
voilà intra-muros voilà et peut-être
allez maintenant peut-être dans tous les
territoires français pourquoi pas les
jouer dans les DOM-TOM voilà et voilà
j'espère que qui m'attendront voilà
merci oui on est on a Dominique je crois
de 20 minutes.fr Dominique il est où
bonsoir Dominique
bonsoir
vous considérez-vous comme meilleur
joueur de Badel au meilleur animateur
télé aujourd'hui en 2023 aujourd'hui je
vous dis la vérité en 2023 je pour
l'instant je suis animateur télé avant
tout et le paddle voilà c'est c'est si
j'étais si j'étais un grand joueur de
paddle je serai dans le top 100 pour
l'instant je ne suis que 177e et je dois
beaucoup à mes partenaires voilà merci
d'autres questions je crois qu'on a
Stéphane de l'écho républicain oui oui
Stéphane bonsoir Stéphane merci bonsoir
Stéphane
de l'écho républicain sentez-vous qu'il
y ait un réel engouement mais beaucoup
plus prononcé ça
très bien depuis que vous médiatisez ce
sport justement dans vos émissions ou
vos réseaux sociaux
en fait être c'est très peu mes degré en
fait cette conférence
ils avaient pas besoin de moi le Paddle
est en train d'exploser il vient
d'exploser partout dans le monde et en
France voilà ça suit son cours mais
c'est vrai que voilà j'ai pas porté ma
pierre à l'édifice tu sais Stéphane je
serai très heureux oui on a une question
de quoi doremont paddle polémique
magazine il se dit dans les milieux
autorisés que vous êtes en train de
créer avec plusieurs partenaires une
ligue en paramètre en parallèle avec
perte plein de personnalités et beaucoup
de people ce que c'est vrai ça non c'est
pas vrai c'est pas vrai et tournons à
l'international notamment non je vais
faire certainement un tournoi à
l'international très bientôt on parle de
vous au Qatar en Arabie Saoudite
c'est pas possible tu auras un contrat
de 30 millions d'euros
c'est pas 30 millions d'euros mais
il y a un contrôle
sachez que voilà je le dis en
exclusivité
l'ancien numéro 1 français de paddle qui
avait pris sa retraite l'année dernière
Joan Bergeron
accepté on s'est parlé tous les deux et
on va faire toute la saison ensemble
l'année prochaine j'aurai avec Théo
Zapata donc mon partenariat espagnol sur
les très gros toits P2000 sur certains
et Johann va faire toute la saison avec
moi sur les P500 les pays 1500 donc
c'est vraiment un truc important que je
voulais vous dire je sais qu'on en avait
rien à et que vous ne comprenez
rien ce que je vous dis mais voilà je
voulais vous dire donc Johan merci merci
oui Patrick
vous avez vous êtes un peu le Cristiano
Ronaldo du paddle non non si vous êtes
une star du paddle est-ce que vous avez
un rival est-ce qu'il y a quelqu'un que
vous voulez détrôner est-ce que vous
avez un message
Adrien Maigret entraîneur mon ami mais
aussi voilà il est converti une envie
c'est de le battre un jour en tournoi
officiel on s'est rencontré en quart de
finale de féminine il m'a mis une tôle
il y a de ça un mois il est classé
combien je reviendrai il est il est il
est dans le top 10 français depuis des
années c'est un des meilleurs joueurs
français
je crois qu'on a Jeanne de paddle mag
également bonsoir Jeanne
sachez que Raymond j'aime beaucoup il y
a beaucoup votre Raymond aime beaucoup
votre magazine
de paddle mag est-ce que vous voyez
encore sur les cours de paddle dans 10
ans et si oui à quel niveau oui oui je
sais pas quel niveau mais je me vois je
me vois sur les cours de paddle et je me
vois également à vos côtés ici je crois
qu'on a Michel du magazine famille
Michel salut salut
je voulais savoir comment est-ce que
vous arrivez à gérer entre votre
carrière de télé votre carrière sportive
et votre vie personnelle
j'essaie d'allier
franchement j'arrive à journalistes
tout tout pour faire essayer de faire
plaisir à tout le monde mais voilà
aujourd'hui voilà la c'est vrai que la
chaîne une petite contracture aux
adducteurs donc là voilà pas de tournoi
depuis 3 semaines donc voilà je vais je
vais reprendre à fond fin juin je crois
qu'on a Olivia de bien-être.fr oui
Olivia bonsoir Olivia sachez
et des Guillaume également Guillaume
aussi
j'avais une question donc est-ce que
votre
nom on est déstabilisant alors non je
pense que en fait au contraire c'est
vrai qu'au début ça joue mais après ils
oublient en fait ils veulent me défoncer
quand même je crois qu'on a on a Eva de
week-end sport c'était moi c'était une
très bonne question alors et Olivia
Olivia Oliver sachez que Raymond et
Guillaume beaucoup vraiment
Olivia de bien-être.fr ma question
rejoint un peu celle du goût on voit que
depuis quelques mois voir quelques
années vous avez entamé un régime strict
pour être au top physiquement c'est pas
vraiment un régime c'est vrai que je
m'entraîne beaucoup voilà mais voilà
j'ai pas de régime particulier
d'accord mais justement
est-ce que vous vous interdisez des
aliments
j'en prends jamais et le chocolat
[Applaudissements]
on a fait toute cette séquence juste
pour ça applaudissement pour eux merci
chérie il fallait qu'on fasse du
chocolat on a pas de la saison ah non je
retourne au plateau on arrive dans 2
minutes qu'on est en parallèle salut les
séries
[Applaudissements]
comme dans les films
ce gars m'a tué
assassiné oui j'ai
ce congé comme dans le film au ciné
[Musique]
chocolat chocolat
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]